That is a challenge and every artist has
to figure out the right balance.
You don't want to represent a brand
that,
that dishonors your name,
that cheapens you.
Uh,
but you also know that in this climate
with records record sales going down
and,
uh,
with record label spending a lot less
money on marketing,
we need to find other marketing partners
to get our music out.
And so I've entered into strategic
partnerships with different,
with different brands in order to get my
music out to the people.
And I only do it with brands that I
think reflect well on me and that
respect my fans and my music and want to
put out messages that are consistent
with music.
And with,
I think the taste of my thing.